bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous des petits la France insoumise
de la Seine-Saint-Denis on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Julien descuyer de la
Voix du Nord bonjour Julien bonjour
madame on a beaucoup de sujets
commencent par le pouvoir d'achat le
carburant la hausse des prix Elizabeth
borne a annoncé hier une aide pour les
travailleurs modestes qui remplacera la
ristourne à la pompe à partir du 1er
janvier de 100 euros qui concernera la
moitié des Français est-ce que c'est une
bonne chose de cibler ceux qui en ont le
plus besoin selon vous je pense que
c'est pas du tout la bonne réponse en
fait on voit un gouvernement qui bricole
avec des primes d'échecs parce que il
est incapable de changer son logiciel de
fond je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
besoin de sortir de la logique du tout
marché et d'être capable de réguler
l'économie en fonction de nos besoins
véritables et non pas des besoins du
des marchés financiers aujourd'hui on
est vraiment sous ce règne là et donc le
gouvernement voit bien que ça ne marche
plus cette logique de libre-échange qui
d'ailleurs est contestée jusqu'à
jusqu'aux États-Unis d'Amérique c'est
quand même extraordinaire puisque là-bas
400 milliards ont été injectés dans
l'économie cet été dans un plan qui rend
avec ce qu'on connaissait depuis au
moins 40 ans mais en France on s’arque
boot Macron ressemble un peu à un
Giscard dont une sortie du formol voyez
et qui continue la politique
de logiciel non je ne crois pas parce
que globalement le quoi qu'il en coûte
ça a été des milliards
bouleversé à des entreprises notamment
celles du CAC 40 qui ont empoché de
l'argent en dépit du fait que elle
supprimait des emplois en dépit du fait
qu'elle augmentait les prix en dépit du
fait qu'elle ne faisait rien pour la
transition écologique et en dépit du
fait que au bout du bout elle reversait
par milliards les dividendes puisque il
faut savoir les petites entreprises
mais il y a des beaucoup de milliards
bien sûr et je suis pour qu'il y ait un
soutien aux tissu très important de TPE
PME P et ça devrait passer déjà par une
fiscalité plus juste puisque comme vous
le savez vous le savez comme moi les
petites entreprises payent
proportionnellement beaucoup plus
d'impôts que les grandes donc là il y a
quelque chose que le gouvernement ne
veut pas logiciel de prime qui vous
aussi qui vous embête prime défiscalisée
et donc pas de reversement cotisations
donc sur l'énergie il fallait faire
totalement totalement autrement alors je
dis totalement il y a le mot total
oui d'accord explosé c'est c'est profits
donc je pense qu'il vaut mieux euh
s'accaparer les profits de Total
c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que tout cet
argent qui a été dégagé impunément dans
une période de crise reviennent dans le
giron public qu'on ait un pôle public de
l'énergie pour qu'il y a un pilote dans
l'avion qu'on soit pas dépendant de des
logiques de marché mais qu'on puisse
intervenir et par ailleurs si vous
bloquez les prix des produits de
première nécessité c'est à dire
directement à la pompe le consommateur
n'est pas n'est pas ponctionné vous
voyez là on a l'impression d'être
ponctionné deux fois avec la difficulté
à la pompe et ensuite parce que nos
impôts servent à soutenir une économie
qui est une économie qui ne sert pas nos
besoins sur les coupures d'électricité
est-ce que vous avez terrasse je vous
remercie de parler de coupure
d'électricité non de délestage espèce de
nouveaux mots non mais c'est une espèce
de novembre
c'est le terme technique est-ce que vous
êtes
vous avez parfaitement raison je pense
pas
c'est bien d'en revenir à des mots qui
parlent donc il s'agit de coupure
d'électricité vous avez été rassuré par
les déclarations d'Emmanuel Macron qui
dit que cet hiver ont tenir qu'on est un
grand pays en matière énergétique et qui
fustige les scénarios de la peur bah
écoutez tant mieux si on n'a pas de
coupure je pense que ça serait ça serait
raisonnable qu'on n'ait pas de coupure
dans une puissance économique aussi
grande que la France imaginez qu'on ait
des coupures d'électricité mais désolé
mais la parole de Macron n'est pas
parole d'évangile et je constate que en
France on a des ruptures de stock de
doliprane qui l'eût cru qui lui cru et
donc le fait qu'on anticipe ces
problèmes là c'est bien que il n'y a pas
de pilote suffisamment
agissant dans la place comme on l'avait
vu au moment de la crise covid
c'est-à-dire que on a des gouvernements
qui ont dépecé les capacités de l'État
d'organiser de planifier et ce qui est
profondément mais je trouve qu'on l'a vu
aussi avec ma Kinsey en fait McKinsey on
a vu que l'État était obligé de recourir
en tout cas ce sentait croyait obligé de
recourir à des cabinets privés pour
organiser son propre son propre
calendrier ses propres méthodes de
planification etc parce que il sait à
force de coupure budgétaire d'austérité
de coupe-franches dans les les postes de
la haute fonction publique y compris de
la fonction publique en général et bien
au fond il ne sait plus organiser les
choses donc c'est c'est très préoccupant
d'avoir un état qui aujourd'hui ne peut
pas garantir un état désormais mais
c'est coupures d'électricité est-ce
qu'elle pose pas aussi la question de la
baisse de la part du nucléaire dans le
parc français elle pose elle pose la
question de notre production d'énergie
vous savez qu'en ce moment à l'Assemblée
nationale on est en train d'étudier un
texte sur les développements des
énergies renouvelables ce qui est assez
dramatique parce que on fait à l'envers
c'est à dire que le gouvernement fait
tout à l'envers au lieu de commencer par
les objectifs et ça fait 5 ans journée
du produire des énergies renouvelables
nous n'arrivons même pas une somme le
seul pays d'Europe qui n'attend pas ses
propres objectifs en matière de enfin en
matière d'énergie du coup vous allez
atteindre les objectifs non il vit pas
atteindre les objectifs le texte
accélérer les énergies renouvelables il
commence il commence par la
réglementation c'est-à-dire qu'il part
du principe que le problème majeur pour
avoir des énergies renouvelables c'est
un problème de réglementation il n'y a
pas un kopeck 1 euro dans ce non mais il
y a pas d'argent mis dans cette loi ce
n'est pas une loi 4 donc moi je sais pas
comment on crée massivement
notre vote n'est pas encore arrêtée
puisqu'on essaye d'obtenir des choses
donc en jugera sur pièce à la fin du
texte mais la logique de marché
notamment sur les questions biodiversité
oui alors le problème le classique
conditionnera votre oui il est très
technique il y a différents je veux pas
parler à la [__] le chef de fil nous
nous jugerons sur pièce à la fin mais je
vais vous dire la n'écoutez pas de voter
pour ah non je pense pas qu'on va non ça
ça me paraît pas possible jouer entre
l'abstention et le vote contre
j'essaie de vous expliquer au lieu
d'avoir d'abord une loi qui dit quels
sont les grands objectifs d'accord pour
notamment qu'à horizon 2050 on est 100%
d'énergie renouvelable en tout cas c'est
notre point notre objectif c'est notre
objectif il est ambitieux mais c'est
notre objectif d'essayer de voir comment
on peut avancer vers 100% d'énergie
renouvelable le gouvernement commence
pas par là il commence par un texte sur
la réglementation et qui va en fait
casser un certain nombre de règles de
marché pour aller vers du grès agréé et
penser que finalement ça va fonctionner
tout seul par la magie voyez de de
l'offre et de la demande on va faire
exploser le nombre de objectifs en
termes de d'énergie de renouvelable de
développement de l'éolien au Shore de
développement d'éolien terrestre en tout
cas il y a l'objectif de 40 de 40
champs-éolien au sort
le problème c'est que en fait il
faudrait se poser la question de notre
industrie pour les produire
et nous nous proposons de multiplier par
trois pour arriver à 200 000 emplois
directement consacrés à ces énergies
renouvelables il n'y a pas de plan
aujourd'hui du gouvernement il n'y a pas
d'investissement prévu il n'y a pas
d'argent qui est mis pour le faire et on
laisse faire le marché et on pense que
ça va se régler comme ça en effet nous
sommes en désaccord avec cette logique
nous pensons qu'il est temps d'investir
massivement et
on va passer de suite on a beaucoup de
sujet à voir d'abord les retraites
Julien oui une petite question puisque
hier il y a eu une réunion autour de la
première ministre et du président de la
République de la majorité sur ce sur ce
sujet des retraites sujets inflammables
on comprend que il reste encore des
arbitrages à faire entre peut-être une
ouverture vers soi une 65 ans hdgal
allongement de la durée cotisation
ou accélération de la réforme Touraine
de montation des
trimestres ou bien on reste sur 6 25 ans
est-ce que dans tous les cas toute façon
c'est pour vous une déclaration de
guerre moi je suis abasourdi que le
débat soit 64 ans ou 65 ans
d'allongement d'âge légal de départ à la
retraite une écrasante majorité de
Français est opposée opposée à
travailler plus longtemps il n'y a
aucune raison de briser notre système et
de nous faire travailler plus longtemps
puisque le système lui-même a
répartition aujourd'hui n'est pas en
péril c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est le
corps le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites qui a fait des estimations et
en gros il est en déficit de combien on
parle de quoi 10 milliards 10 milliards
sur 340 milliards annuels de prestations
donc je vous ai dit combien de
dividendes reversés sur une année là 70
milliards comprennent la mesure des
choses je dis qu'on prenne la mesure des
choses donc on va nous faire travailler
jusqu'à 65 ans donc en réalité plus
parce que si vous dites l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ou 65 ans ça veut dire que
dans la vraie vie suivant le moment où
vous avez commencé et le caractère plus
ou moins haché de votre retraite vous
allez plutôt partir autour de 67 68 ans
il y a eu une promesse de d'Elizabeth
borne pour ne pas bouger cet âge-là non
mais vous rendez compte est-ce que vous
rendez compte de ce que ça veut dire
pour des millions de gens est-ce que
vous savez qu'on a aujourd'hui un
million de personnes qui pendant plus de
20 heures par semaine font des gestes
répétés de façon très cadencée est-ce
que vous savez qu'il y a 2 millions de
personnes qui portent des charges lourds
10 heures par mois et vous allez
demander à ces gens de travailler
jusqu'à 65 ans par mois non non par mois
et qui vont se dire pas mal c'est déjà
pas mal je vous assure et qui vont alors
qu'est-ce que vous allez travailler pour
face à cette offensive gouvernementale
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
concrètement très concrètement s'est mis
en ordre de marche très très fortement
d'abord je suis très heureuse de voir
que les syndicats se sont organisés en
inter syndicale et ont décidé d'en
découdre sur la contre-réforme des
retraites et vont sans doute appeler à
une journée de nos premières journées de
mobilisation donc on est très attentif à
cela et nous les avons d'ailleurs tout
auditionné les organisations syndicales
quand je dis nous c'est à la fois les
députés de la nupes et les sénateurs de
tous les groupes de gauche et nous
travaillons ensemble nous aurons une
conférence de presse la semaine
prochaine commune avec un texte dans
lequel nous disons donc un gros projet
vous allez présenter là pour l'instant
nous allons dire que nous ne voulons pas
d'un allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite et que nous réaffirmons que
nous réaffirmons notre horizon qui est
celui d'un départ à 60 ans avec 40 à
nuités ça c'est notre horizon
politique et syndicale ensemble nous
estimons qu'il n'y a pas péril en la
demeure c'est-à-dire que l'argument
financier est un faux argument
totalement mensongé il n'y a pas besoin
urgemment de mettre à bas notre système
d'autant que dans les projections en
2040 le système revient à l'équilibre et
que par ailleurs tout ça c'est sans
compter la capacité à faire en sorte que
on aille vers le plein emploi c'est
toutes ces projections on part du
principe que on reste quelque part dans
une situation où on n'est pas capable de
chômage de maths ce sera pour quand
autre la mobilisation de mobilisation
commune politique syndicale parce qu'il
y aura une manifestation
la mobilisation politique par définition
elle aura notamment lieu dans
l'hémicycle quand si et quand le projet
de loi arrivera ça c'est une première
chose et puis nous prenons des
initiatives nous avons auditionné les
organisations syndicales nous allons pas
de auditionner un certain nombre
d'économies nous faisons une conférence
de presse vous allez nous voir déployer
en tout cas la détermination de la nupes
et de tous les groupes de gauche au
Parlement est totalement
gouvernement nous l'avons déjà fait
reculer la dernière fois je m'en
souviens bien parce que j'étais en
première loge avec nos 17000 amendements
et la mobilisation dans la rue c'est
pareil quand le texte arrive des
milliers d'amendements on va réfléchir
l'obstation parlementaire sera total
c'est ce que vous devez nous la
détermination sera totale mais ça
passera par des abonnements la
détermination sera totale et
vous le texte sur l'immigration
puisqu'elle isabelle est venu devant les
députés avec Gérald Darmanin Olivier
Dussol pour présenter les grandes lignes
un débat avant même la présentation du
texte est-ce que vous dites c'est la
bonne méthode écoutez on en peut plus ça
fait 29 textes en 40 ans sur
l'immigration depuis 1980 depuis même
plus que 40 ans vous imaginez
le Parlement est entendu de venir
débattre avant de présenter le texte en
conseil des ministres écoutez au sujet
sur lequel on pourrait avoir des débats
le gouvernement choisi d'avoir un temps
programmé comme ça de débat sur
l'immigration qui est le thème favori de
l'extrême droite c'est un choix qui
n'aurait pas été le nôtre je vous assure
il veut dire quoi qu'est-ce que vous
sous-entendez
la première chose mais la deuxième c'est
que dans les thèmes choisis comme
prioritaire on pourrait par exemple
avoir une deux heures de débat sur les
retraites on aurait pu
non mais alors il y a eu sans doute
peut-être que
ça soit dessus d'ailleurs il concerte et
puis après
une promesse de d'Emmanuel Macron que de
faire un débat régulier d'ailleurs qui a
été interrompu par le covid sur
l'immigration donc il le fait je vous
repose la question on aurait pu dire que
hier puisqu'on avait deux heures de
débats sans vote à l'Assemblée nationale
priorité mais sur le contenu du texte
par exemple excusez-moi c'est vrai sur
les titres de séjour
vous avez raison sur les titres de
séjour particulier pour les métiers en
tension est-ce que c'est pas quand même
une voix de régularisation qui pourrait
vous satisfaire nous on est pour en
effet la régularisation de ceux qui sont
sur notre territoire un travail sur
notre territoire mais si vous voulez
c'est l'entrée qui ne va pas c'est
l'entrée qui ne va pas parce que nous
nous estimons pas qu'il y a un crise de
l'immigration donc un problème de trop
de migrants logique de submersion que
semble valider le gouvernement et
notamment monsieur Darmanin nous
estimons qu'il y a une crise de
l'accueil c'est pas du tout la même
chose il y a pas de submersion vous
pouvez regarder toutes les enquêtes
sociologiques tous les travaux qui sont
faits sur le sujet ça n'est pas vrai
le texte donc de quoi parle-t-on
des des procédures pourquoi autant de
texte en permanence pour durcir en
réalité
il y a une réforme des préfectures
attendez voir la réforme moi j'attends
de voir elle est importante vous-même et
à raison de Boris Vallot aussi a rappelé
le désordre actuel c'est un an de
procédure on cherche à réduire à 6 mois
ça c'est plutôt une bonne chose non mais
il faut embaucher moi j'ai eu la
discussion à plusieurs reprises avec
j'ai envie de dire les préfets parce que
dans la durée il y a eu plusieurs de
Seine-Saint-Denis ce qui est terrifiant
en Seine-Saint-Denis c'est que on n'a
pas la capacité d'appliquer l'État de
droit de faire en sorte que nous soyons
dans un état de droit donc c'est pas un
problème de procédure pour vous c'est un
problème d'effectueux ils n'ont pas les
effectifs ça n'est pas ils ne peuvent
pas appliquer l'État de droit vous
rendez compte ce que je suis en train de
vous dire vous imaginez un préfet qui
lui-même est capable de dire je ne suis
pas en état d'appliquer l'État de droit
parce que je n'ai pas suffisamment de
personnel pour recevoir un temps les
gens et vérifier si leur dossier leur
donne droit ou pas un titre de séjour
c'est quand même effrayant absolument
effrayant donc on a une crise de
l'accueil et ce que fait le gouvernement
avec ses débats et ses lois à répétition
qui globalement durcissent les
conditions d'accueil et qui globalement
ne lutte pas contre les frontextes
contre toutes les logiques qui sont des
logiques qui sont particulièrement
violentes voire parfois criminelles
vis-à-vis des migrants et bien ce
gouvernement il lutte non pas contre une
hypothétique submersion des migrants
mais comme l'a dit ma collègue Elsa
faussillon c'est plutôt une logique de
submersion du Front national des idées
du Front national fin du rassemblement
national de l'extrême droite c'est à ça
que contribue aujourd'hui le
gouvernement on va poser une question
sur la santé oui santé alors on est dans
une à l'aube d'une Neuvième Vague nous
disent nous disent les chiffres et ce
qu'il faut pour vous réinvestir les les
gestes barrières remettre le masque dans
les transports par exemple écoutez que
chacun se protège que la vaccination
puisse perdurer et que personne les plus
fragiles parce que c'est ça le plus
important c'est que les personnes les
plus fragiles devant ce virus puisse
être le mieux protégé possible donc oui
il faut rappeler les gestes barrières je
pense que là aujourd'hui si on disait
aux Français allez on refait tout on
remet des masques partout des gestes
je pense que le nom nous aurions un
problème de consentement tel contexte
madame il est utile voit légitime de
réintégrer des soignants non vaccinés
alors la proposition de loi de ma
collègue Caroline Fiat qui était
présente dans notre niche visait
notamment et c'était intéressant le
débat qui a eu à ce moment-là visait
notamment à répondre à une situation que
nous avons chez les ultramarins dans les
outre-mer
non mais pas en France vous allez c'est
plus que marginal les personnels
soignants
les personnels soignants non vaccinés
c'est c'est une goutte d'eau parmi donc
destination des territoires je dis juste
que en revanche nous avons une situation
est une situation critique chez les
ultramarins et que il y a là je crois
qu'il y a la nécessité quelque part
d'effacer l'ardoise des tensions qu'il y
a eu qui a eu et qui sont en partie liés
au drame du chlordécone et de la
défiance à l'égard de la parole de la
parole de la police
justement est-ce que est-ce qu'elle
légitimait le fait que Caroline Fiat
puisse comment dire juger nécessaire de
d'investir une niche parlementaire
rassemblement nationale telle que ça
avait été proposé par le groupe
rassemblement vous avez vu ce qu'a dit
de façon extrêmement claire notre groupe
il n'y aura il n'y aura pas de
propositions de loi portée par notre
groupe dans la niche du rassemblement
il n'y aura pas est-ce qu'elle a fait
une erreur
politiquement parlant pas de piège nous
ne serons pas dans cette niche voilà
donc moi je vais vous dire les choses
franchement est-ce qu'elle devait
refuser tout de suite il y a un moment
donné il faut avoir une personnes vers
tes bras politiques mais justement à
l'Assemblée aussi toute collusion
collusion avec l'extrême droite est
inacceptable est impossible est
impensable je peux pas vous dire plus
nettement donc c'est non voilà c'est non
et je pense en effet qu'il faut à chaque
fois être très clair sur cela d'autant
plus qu'il y a un petit jeu
on le voit bien des médias qu'on dit des
grands médias mainstream en permanence
expliquer que rassemblement national et
France insoumise c'est la même chose qui
est quand même est insupportable parce
que si on est un tout petit peu
rationnel on sait que nous proposons des
voies qui sont quasiment en tout point
radicalement opposé radicalement opposé
voilà donc il faut arrêter avec ça il
faut je demande que que vraiment chacun
est conscience de la gravité de cette
assimilation de l'un à l'autre et quand
il s'agit de balayer devant notre porte
il faut en effet que nous ayons une
colonne vertébrale suffisamment solide
pour ne jamais se retrouver piégé
à la insoumise parce qu'il y a des voix
qu'il y a des voix chez vous qui disent
que ben si pour faire tomber le
gouvernement il faut s'associer avec le
RN et ben on s'associe avec le RS non
mais c'est pas on s'associe pas
attention faites attention hier par
exemple sur la loi love me voilà sur les
votes vous pouvez avoir
des groupes enfin l'extrême droite et la
majorité qui vote ensemble ils l'ont
fait sur le la loi pouvoir d'achat
est-ce que vous dites
est-ce que vous dites pour autant ah bah
c'est la même chose la macronie elle
extrême droite et sur la loi pouvoir
d'achat ils ont voté la même intégration
des soignants vous vous voteriez la même
chose mais pas d'association on met des
bornes c'est pas de motion ou de censure
commune ça n'arrivera pas vous voyez ce
que je veux dire mais de dire qu'à aucun
moment les députés des uns des
différents groupes vont appuyer sur le
même bouton écouter soyons raisonnables
ça n'a pas de sens donc ça il faut
arrêter ce petit jeu faut arrêter ce
petit jeu une dernière question Julien
dernière question encore mardi prochain
Adrien catenens passera devant le juge
dans le cadre d'une procédure de plaie
découpable pour des violences conjugales
à l'égard de son épouse
des décisions sur son maintien au sein
du groupe et les filles seront elles
prises à la suite de cette décision tout
à fait et nous avons entamé des
discussions au sein de notre groupe pour
réfléchir justement à ce que nous allons
faire alors nous attendons la décision
de justice donc pour les connus on va
dire c'est un [__] coupable donc tu
seras oui
d'abord ça peut évoluer moi j'ai entendu
les déclarations de Céline catenens qui
parle de violences répétées physique et
morale sur plusieurs années donc moi
le premier pas
ce que la justice va retenir est-ce
qu'elle va faire un simple appel à la
loi ou est-ce que au bout du compte ça
sera renvoyé devant une Cour Pénale moi
je ne sais vous vous savez peut-être moi
je ne sais pas voilà non mais ça veut
dire que il y aura pas de il y aura pas
de d'appel à la démission c'est ce que
vous nous dites
nous n'avons pas dit que nous voulions
une démission d'Adrien catenens la
question est juste et celle de
l'appartenance à notre groupe est celle
de des conditions qui permettraient
Adrien catenas de revenir c'est ça le
sujet voilà et on en débat et on en
débat c'est pas facile c'est pas facile
à bon parce que ce sont des
problématiques nouvelles liées à la
vague me to donc auquel nous devons
faire face que nous avons un devoir
d'exemplarité évidemment et en même
temps quand je dis c'est il y a comme
c'est dans notre groupe c'est un
camarade donc c'est forcément toujours
très douloureux comme moment mais nous
avons dit que nous voulions prendre une
décision politique et qui repose sur nos
principes et qui nous permettent que
nous affirmions aussi notre engagement
politiquement parlant je parle pas de la
décision de justice politiquement
parlant pour vous le maximum de
l'Assomption ça serait une exclusion du
groupe lui demanderez pas de
démissionner de son mandat de je vous
réponds sur rien là-dessus je pense que
c'est important qu'il y ait une décision
du groupe elle n'est pas prise nous
attendons d'être éclairés par l'addition
de justice et après on verra je peux
avoir une très dernière question très
rapidement il y a l'assemblée du
mouvement
samedi samedi est-ce que vous ferez
partie de la direction
je n'en sais strictement rien non c'est
strictement rien parce que pas de
nouvelles il y a pas de nouvelles
jusqu'à présent
ma connaissance je ne suis pas invité
samedi à l'assemblée représentative donc
je ne sais pas je ne peux pas répondre à
votre question c'est un peu quand même
étonnant quand même de pas être invité
je ne fais pas partie de la commission
qui a organisé cela je j'avoue que j'ai
pas tous les éléments pour comprendre
exactement comment se réorganise le
mouvement et pour ma part je suis
incapable de vous dire aujourd'hui si je
vais participer pour vous mais voilà
mais je ne dis pas que d'ici là nous
aurons des réponses et merci beaucoup
Clémentine Autain la Une de La Voix du
Nord c'est peut-être une éclaircie pour
camaïeu la marque camaïeu par Celio
merci beaucoup Julien merci Clémentine